à côté des mythiques soldats de plomb
d'autres plus surprenants comme les
playmobil en tout 1870 figurines se bat
pour raconter la guerre de 1870 la
raconter aux enfants et aux parents car
ce conflit reste méconnu pourtant vous
en avez entendu parler c'est celui où la
france a perdu l'alsace et la lorraine
c'était le but aussi de présenter des
saynètes avec des jouets actuelle donc
les lego les playmobil pour justement
attirer les familles les enfants et les
intéresser davantage à cette histoire de
la guerre de 1870 et de la bataille qui
s'est jouée ici
allouani le 2 décembre 1870 qui a fait
quand même près de 9000 victimes parmi
les mises en scène de cette bataille de
loi ni en eure-et-loir celle en lego car
en partie fabriqué rodolphe venu ce jour
là animé un atelier en complément de
l'exposition
moi je trouvais un immense plaisir à
créer des thèmes
sont entre guillemets sous contrainte et
surtout a prouvé qu'on était capable
avec des lego de faire n'importe quelles
thématiques liées à l'histoire
la preuve avec sacha lui a choisi de
créer une espèce de bastide bien plus
ancienne que 1870 mais toujours lié à
l'histoire
ça peut-être pas un grand rapport avec
cette guerre mais ça a servi pour les
romains c'est là c'est plus compliqué
pas de contrainte d'âge de temps ni de
thème
l'idée est de laisser aller sa
créativité avec l'espoir que cet atelier
cette exposition marque les esprits
pour ne pas oublier et surtout ne pas
répéter ces massacres du passé